scp-035 versus dr bright the timeless  battle of an anomalous body stealing  medallion versus an anomalous body  stealing mask but who would win the day  let's find out  scp-035 is functionally immortal it has  frightening psychological effects over  its victims and secretes caustic black  liquid however this comes at a major  cost of slowly rotting its own host dr  bright is also functionally immortal  thanks to the scp-963 amulet which is  also an incredibly effective weapon  against non-anomalous human targets  including instant brain death upon  contact however his human hosts are  often just as vulnerable as normal  humans though he may not be eldritch his  tactical knowledge and experience in  dealing with anomalies as well as the  fact that his medallion won't ruin the  physical integrity of his hosts gives  him an advantage over this nasty mask  personally we'd give this one to dr  bright